there's a new geography champion from
California vine Khatron John took home
the title at the 30th annual National
Geographic EB yesterday he beat nine
other finalists chip Reid was there and
joins us from National Geographic
headquarters in Washington DC which even
I can find
good morning chip good morning you know
these kids were competing for a grand
total of 85 thousand dollars in college
scholarships college scholarships and
they're only in the fourth to eighth
grade but I tell you some of them
sounded like they've already graduated
from college so we're about to learn who
is the 2018 National Geographic Bee
champion before reaching the
championship round these finalists first
had to beat more than 50 of the nation's
top geography whiz kids surviving a
gauntlet of brain twisting questions and
heartbreaking eliminations to make it
into the top ten drumroll please and
step into the spotlight alongside be
moderator and CBS Sunday morning
correspondent Mo Rocca
these junior geographers faced the
cameras like celebrities and then set
out to prepare for the big stage I just
want to be cool and calm I'm gonna cram
a lot the group preassembled Wednesday
at National Geographic headquarters to
put their knowledge to the ultimate test
this state capital on the Pearl River
was named after a president of the
United States after more than ten rounds
of questions the top two finalists faced
off head to head Lebanon has a
population most similar to which South
American country and vinca Ranjan edged
out Anushka Buddha coat the correct
answer is Paraguay to become this year's
champion the answer to the last question
part way did you know that was the right
answer
no you guessed yeah I like eliminated a
feel and then guess that guess even
impressed Raqqa a self-proclaimed
geography nerd they should each run
their own think-tank they are their own
think-tank so what are you gonna do now
to celebrate if you want to feel really
stupid hang out with these kids for a
while they are absolutely amazing at one
point they turned the tables on Mo Rocca
and asked him some geography questions
he got some of them right but he was
stumped by one what is the highest point
in New Jersey the answer High Point New
Jersey that makes you feel stupid right
and who is very Tuo's who is buried in
great alright where's the Indianapolis
500 yeah that's a good one thank you so
much and congratulations to the winner
there